this is the world's most powerful
Thunderbolt dock for Apple silicon Max
and it is absolutely incredible it has a
ton of features packed in with a very
smart thoughtful Design This is the
ivanky
dcd-10 docking station with 20 ports
built in now if you haven't heard of
ivanky they have been around for a long
time with some of the most popular HDMI
and DisplayPort cables on Amazon very
well rated and they've also made a
docking station before that was also
specifically designed for MacBooks and
they made this dock to go with those
cables in your Macs and be the best dock
that you can possibly get now I've been
using a dock since I got rid of my Intel
Mac Pro and that thing had a ton of
ports built in which was great but with
most other Macs you don't have access to
all of those ports and if you want a
really nice desktop setup well you are
very limited especially with a Macbook
but now with the ivanky docking station
Ultra 20 in one you no longer have to
deal with any issues and I'll explain
how it proved my setup and it's just
designed to be the heartbeat of
blazing's performance for your setup and
it's designed for Professionals for
creatives but of course anybody can use
it now there's a lot of very impressive
things about this but one of the most
impressive is the fact that you can have
a quad monitor setup with four displays
but you also have HDMI as well so
because of that you can have your Mac
display plus four more of which other
dogs still do now I want to show you
guys what's in the box before covering
some of the other really cool things
about it and here's the actual
Thunderbolt doc man this thing has some
have to I missed that that aside Ai and
let's open up the inside here now we
have a little sheet that gives you some
very important information because of
all the ports in a jam packed in here it
is important that you know exactly how
to best use this and I'll go over some
of this information in just a little bit
let's go ahead and open up this package
right here we have some warranty
information right here so make sure you
guys register to take care of that we
have our user manual you also get a QR
code on the back and then we get these
rubber hats they give you four of them
because you can actually set this up to
be either horizontal or flat on your
desk or standing up we have this box
right here and this is the power adapter
now this thing is a 180 watt power
adapter and it is this size and this
power because not only does the power of
the dock itself but this thing has a lot
of pass-through power for your various
devices and then inside of this last box
this is super cool and very unique we
have this special cable that they
created and as you guys can see it has
dual Thunderbolt cables built into one
and that is because this dock has dual
Thunderbolt for chips now because of
this this thing is designed for Apple
silicon Max it is not designed for Intel
versions because they don't have
Thunderbolt 4 and they cannot handle
this many ports with this much
performance of course you have your
power cable and you get an HDMI cable as
well I have to say that the quality is
very very nice on all of these cables
and this plug right here this is
aluminum not plastic so you're getting a
very nice product go set that aside and
let's go ahead and open up the actual
dock itself wow this thing feels solid
it has a nice weight to it and just like
that was at a cable this is all aluminum
this is not plastic now you guys could
see the design of this it's very
different from all the other docks that
are on the market we have a couple
little feet right there with this
aluminum that actually separates the
actual dock here it's a lot of actuals
there but it has a very smart design
because that allows heat to dissipate
not only from the top maybe the sides
but from the bottom as well because you
have that extra separation and that's
designed to keep all of this performance
running a lot cooler than your regular
setup now my previous dock it would get
super super hot and then I have this CF
Express card reader and I used to put it
on top of my Dock and it would actually
stop working because of how hot it got
from all of the heat being trapped so
that is very smart for them to do this
here we have a couple tips on how to
invest use this I'm going to go ahead
and take that off right there you guys
see this has two Downstream ports with
that little line around it because you
have two thighable chips in here and
that's where we grab our special cable
and that pops right in like that the
other side is perfectly spaced to
connect to your MacBook and be able to
give you the full performance with all
of these ports now with my previous
stock I actually had to split up and
connect two Thunderbolt cables
separately one that went to my Dock and
the other one that went to my server
because I use a 6K Pro display xdr
monitor I have a bunch of other
accessories and actually had issues
getting in my full bandwidth and the
full performance through just one port
so this is a very smart design to make
sure that that doesn't happen I'm going
to go ahead and unplug this this and
let's go over all of the ports that
ivanky put into this dock now on the
front here we have a little LED
indicator and then we have two
Thunderbolt USBC ports right here and
both of them are labeled 6K because each
one can handle a 6K display and then
right next to that we have two USB type
B or it's now the cool thing about this
is that they are both 10 gigabit per
second now many docks might have one OSP
Port A lot of them will just have five
gigabit per second ports overall and
this has double the performance for
those ports but not only that looking
lower we have two USB type-c ports here
and both those are also 10 gigabit per
second so you don't get any slowdowns
like you will with other docks because
of those dual Thunderbolts 4 chips
inside now one of them has a little
lightning logo and that's because it
outputs more power than the rest of the
ports but all the ports have a good
amount of power coming out for charging
as well compared to alternative options
now we also have a headphone jack this
is also a combo mic Jack and we have
another headphone jack on the back so
each you want to connect a dedicated
microphone you want to do that to that
front Port because only the front
supports microphones we also have a UHS
type 2 SD card slot right here and a
Micro SD card slot now some docs will
have just one micro or one SD card slot
so it's nice to have both because I do
use both of those kind of cards and then
flipping to the back here we see a bunch
more boards now I already showed you
guys that special connector that they
give you right next to we have the power
input and then we have a Kensington lock
right here so if you want to lock this
up so nobody could steal it you have
that option now right here we have two
more ports for another two 6K place now
of course it doesn't have to be 6K but
this is the only dock that I know that
can power for displays if you have a
Macbook that can support that which I'll
go over the compatibility list in just a
bit now right next to it we have two 4K
60fps HDMI port so you don't have to use
the USBC DisplayPort ports for that now
here we have three more 10 gigabit per
second USB type A ports that is crazy
impressive because no matter where you
plug in you're gonna get the full
performance you don't have to compromise
and then we have an ethernet port now
this is another cool thing because a lot
of dogs that have a good amount of ports
well they have to go with one gigabit
per second because they just don't have
enough bandwidth with one Thunderbolt
cable this one can also Supply 2.5
gigabit per second so two and a half
times the performance and then we have
an optical audio output which is is also
very unique so if you want to connect to
high-end audio equipment if you want to
have a surround sound setup or for other
purposes you have that output built in
as well you don't have to use that three
and a half mil Jack but you do have
another one on the back if you want to
split up your microphone or speakers or
if you want to have a port in the front
for headphones and then a port on the
back for a set of speakers once again
only the front Port supports microphones
so that brings us to our full 20 ports
on this bad boy and with the ability to
have all of these ports and with really
good bandwidth why would you want to
have a dock that only uses one cable
with Thunderbolt chip that has to slow
things down when you can have two
Thunderbolt 4 chips with a dual
connection
which does not limit you so with that
said what do I have plugged into my
setup well on my desk of course I have
my MacBook and I have the maxim chip in
there so I support for a lot of displays
and then I also have my 6K display
plugged into that so typically I use one
very large display and then I plug into
that server that I talked about which
has 120 terabytes of storage which our
editor and Vadim also plugs into now on
top of that I have my desktop speakers
plugged in on the back and I also have a
UPS station plugged in in one of those
USB ports which communicates to my Mac
and then I have my CF Express card
reader plugged in as well and nothing
gets full performance those cards are
insanely fast and they are not limited
by the ports that are on this thing
which is really nice and I use both that
reader along with the SD and micro SD to
have full connections to my MacBook when
I'm dealing with video and audio files
now I also have a lot of other ports
available so when I need to plug in an
extern Journal SSD I have no issues if I
need to plug a couple of them in I'm not
limited also cables for charging my
phone or my wireless mouse or my
keyboard I can also plug that in without
having a fumble or unplug something from
my MacBook in order to be able to plug
that in so when I come into my office I
just set my Mac down and plug in that
one cable that has two Thunderbolt
Connections in it and I have access to
everything that I need which is a single
plug-in including that display all the
accessories and my MacBook gets charged
at the same time not as a huge selling
point of the dot making it very easy to
be able to set up at your desk and then
unplug your laptop and be able to take
it with you on the go now I mentioned
the quad display support using my
MacBook but of course that does vary
depending on what kind of Mac you have
so here is the full sheet of support so
you guys could see it you could do quad
displays you can also do triple 6K and
then you could do a 4K display if you
have a Max ship now if you have a pro
chip you can go all the way up to dual
6K displays with that setup and it also
applies to Mac Mini with the M2 Pro chip
but if you're not using the port for
video transmission they aren't wasted as
they could be used as 40 gigabit per
second Thunderbolt and 15 watt fast
charging ports now if you have an M1 or
the M2 Chip Apple lemon the amount of
displays that you could output you have
the One internal display and then you
could do one additional external display
and that could be a single 4K a single
5K or a single 6K display with those M1
and M2 equipped Max so if you have one
of those you can't output quad displays
but you still have access to a ton of
different ports with this Dock and then
of course you are future proof If you
update date later to a pro or a Max chip
or if the M3 allows to have more
external displays which is what we're
hearing you'll be able to keep this dock
long term and then it will have more
functionality later down the line so
from all the docs that I've seen on the
market and the ones that I'd use myself
and I've used probably about three of
them over the last few years this thing
has the smartest design with really good
cool link it has a ton of ports that are
not limited because of bandwidth issues
since you have that cable that has dual
Thunderball Connections in just one
table and even though it's using dual
with two Thunderbolt 4 chips built into
this well it's still just one cable that
you plug in with ivanky's design and
that cable that they gave you so if you
guys want to get something that is the
most powerful flexible kind of future
proof design for Apple silicon backs
well this is what you want to get go
ahead and check out the link down below
to get a really good deal on this dock
you can pick one up let me know your
thoughts on it click that Circle above
to subscribe and check out one of those
videos right over there
foreign